uh you heard the interview with mr
panetta there and i suppose his attitude
could best be described um
as uh general greta rian
why isn't the france cheering for this
alliance between its two nato
uh allies
you know good morning
well first you you have to understand
that
what was at stake was for france was
much more than a contract uh because uh
providing 12 summaries to australia was
for us a strategic choice
we wanted to build a strategic
partnership
which would be uh the pillar of our
indo-pacific strategy
uh two french presidents uh were visited
recently australia you know it's 20
hours of flight from paris
but there were a lot of meetings uh our
navies were training together a few
weeks ago there were big training
between indian french and australian uh
navies uh and so suddenly uh not only we
we lose an important contract but a
strategic partnership is thrown away
overnight
and and there is another partnership
which is created uh announced at least
and france is excluded from the for from
the partnership and also the i think the
americans and the australians have had
injuries uh insults to the injury uh
because suddenly we discover they've
been plotting in our back for weeks and
months uh we are allies you know it's
not a way of twitching allies
but there's
there's absolutely no reason why uh the
united kingdom and the united states
can't be
allies both with australia and with
france and also australia can be an ally
with us and we're with france
tell the truth here you lost out on a
commercial deal 4.7 billion is a lot of
money and you are just cross about it
well first on the
on the the figures you know really under
what you said 47 billion uh british
pounds i think to the french it was only
something like six or seven billions uh
because the rest was for buying american
uh weapon system and for building them
in in australia where you don't have
actually shipyards
uh so it was not you know well it was
not 50 billion
british pounds taken from the from the
french you know really it wasn't
important but it was not that critical
uh so why it makes that a big fuss about
it
no but there is the first and i insist
on that the first is political uh really
as i've said uh we have been undercut uh
in what we considered as a very
important political uh choice and we
have been undercut by our
closest allies in a sense uh the way it
has been done is amazing you know really
we were not consulted we were not warned
and basically uh uh we we were told uh
through food achieving uh
think of it you know for months british
americans australians have been plotting
in our back basically saying ha we are
going to take uh this contract from the
french uh you don't behave this way
between allies again france has been the
first european country active in the
indo-pacific area you know right now you
have uh a craft career british aircraft
carrier there but our
career was there three years ago
all right well you're you're making the
case that this isn't um what might look
from london uh like a fit of peak but
explain one thing which is a puzzle here
in london you withdrew ambassadors from
canberra and washington but not london
well i think you know we don't consider
that uh the uk has been uh really uh has
played a critical role uh as you know uh
the the a lot of the so-called uk uh
technology uh in the nuclear field as
for the nuclear deterrence force uh is
actually american and depending on on
the americans uh so we considered uh
that uh the whole of the uk in a sense
was subsidiary uh that the impulse was
coming from canberra on on one side and
from washington on the other one
is is that a not very diplomatic way of
saying that uh london isn't very
important in french calculations anymore
i will again i'm not a diplomat anymore
uh but i think our minister foreign
affairs has said that in the in this
uh as we said in french uh uh the uk has
been the fifth wheel of of of the
carriage
well uh uh it seems that um the one
thing that's not in in much supply here
is diplomacy what was it very diplomatic
for you to tweet that the uk is now run
by a monty python government
well you know we're announcing that we
that the uk is going back to imperial
measures it's really and so it will join
uh myanmar and the u.s you know it's
it's frankly it's amazing you know it
makes uh you know it's it's really icing
for me it's extremely funny
and again i'm not a diplomat anymore i
was an ambassador but i'm retired and
i'm using the the the freedom of
retirement to to say
what i believe
all right well
all right well let's let's leave for the
moment what our americans would say
uh uh would call a french dis of london
and let's just return to france itself
are we seriously here seeing the
beginnings of a return under president
macron to a kind of goalism uh an
independent
french foreign policy
well so first i think again let's go
beyond the storm of the today's storm
and we had president obama which
really
was totally indifferent towards europe i
was ambassador at the time after that we
had
uh trump who was of style
towards europe and now you have
president biden as you have said
yourself there was afghanistan and now
there is this this story but frankly
when president biden came to europe in
june there was on the american side
absolutely uh no show of interest for a
real cooperation with the europeans the
european union has had send to
washington a long list of of potential
fields of cooperation and nothing came
out of of washington so i think it's
it's natural that today we raised the
question saying
basically europeans wake up basically
the americans are having pivoted so much
to the to asia to china as you have said
okay
the americans don't care so much about
europe you look ukraine syria libya
all our environment is in flames and the
americans are not there so that's reason
why president macron is saying maybe we
should have what he calls strategic
autonomy it's not anti-american it's
simply looking at what america is today